on va d'abord entamé le débat de ce club
consacré aux éoliennes les énergies
renouvelables dont les éoliennes en mer
sont une priorité pour barbara pompili
leur développement se poursuit en france
mais ces éoliennes elles font naître de
plus en plus de réticences dans la
population ce qui a poussé le
gouvernement cette semaine a annoncé une
série de mesures et va nous rejoindre
pour ce débat jacques pallas bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous monsieur
le maire je vous laisse le temps de vous
installer le temps pour nous de faire le
point sur le déploiement de ses parcs
éoliens en france avec marion d'alpage
après avoir fait rage aux dernières
régionales le débat sur l'équipement de
la france en éoliennes retrouve le
devant de la scène à la faveur de la
présidentielle mais où en est on
aujourd'hui dans l'hexagone et quels
sont les objectifs avec un parc de 17 6
gigawatts de puissance installée
l'énergie éolienne assuré fin 2020 près
de 7,9 pour cent de la production
électrique française contre 6,3 en 2019
la france veut faire passer la part de
l'éolien dans la production électrique à
20% soit 33 2 gigawatts de puissance
installée d'ici 2028 pour y parvenir le
parc éolien français doit passer de 9000
ma aujourd'hui à 14000 ma d'ici cette
date l'éolien en mer devrait lui
représenté en quarts de cet objectif
mais le rythme de croisière espérer pour
y parvenir est loin d'être atteint les
retards des procédures d'autorisation et
les blocages administratifs freine la
croissance de l'éolien en france et
jacques pallas vous avez rejoint pour ce
débat vous êtes mère de georges sur
arnon saint georges saint georges c'est
dans l'indre et vous avez implanté dans
votre commune 19 éoliennes plus on vous
allez nous le dira pourquoi ce choix
d'implanter autant derrière dans votre
commune parce que quand vous êtes élu
dans une commune que vous êtes
confrontés à transition énergétique
on est bien obligé de regarder et le
premier projet ça a été le parc éolien
et après nous avons dérivé sur la
transition énergétique le photovoltaïque
autour des trois axes les économies
d'énergie la réduction des gaz à effet
de serre et le développement des
énergies renouvelables quand vous êtes
élu vous êtes oublie de regarder devoir
et effectivement d'appliquer donc les
directives que nous imposer quand même
le gouvernement et la planète et le
climat
on tire un bénéfice vous de
l'implantation de ces éoliennes pour
votre commune alors accrochez vous le
bénéfice est énorme eh bien oui parce
qu'on est des communes en dépenses et
quand vous avez des recettes fiscales
qui sont nouvelles vous est très content
et c'est ce qui va alimenter les projets
donc on ne peut pas le regarder d'un
oeil différent c'est aussi bien pour le
photovoltaïque pour l'éolien c'est
combien par exemple alors
exactement très exactement pour 14
éoliennes pascal lassaigne sur la
commune de mini il faut 14 éoliennes
âgées 144 mille euros donc de recettes
fiscales ça représente 30% de mon budget
et quand le gouvernement tous les ans et
réduit donc les dgf les dotations et
compagnie avaient coûté voilà ça fait du
bien et ça nous permet de développer des
projets en association avec la
population
d'abord je respecte son choix il a été
élu démocratiquement donc il fait le
choix que la population lui a confiée
cela étant c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le
développement de l'éolien terrestre et
où suppose aussi un problème parce qu'on
voit qu'il ya un mitage c'est sur le
territoire national qui a pas une
organisation globale que chaque commune
peut faire comme elle le souhaite je ne
doute pas que monsieur le maire choisit
les endroits les plus adaptées pour
installer ces éoliennes mais
ça pose aussi un problème en terme de
deux visuels de paysages de nuisance ça
peut poser des problèmes en terme de
nuisances
auditive
avec des ondes avec des choses comme ça
donc
moi je comprends par contre évidemment
le monsieur le maire quand il dit que
salle lur ça lui rapporte un tiers de
son but c'est ce que tu viens dire à
tire d'aile un tiers de son budget donc
c'est énorme pour une petite commune 144
mille euros c'est considérable c'est une
carotte intéressante par ailleurs c'est
pas sa motivation principale il a bien
dire c'est c'est le mix énergétique c
voilà donc justement
compilé elle dit que le développement de
l'éolien est plus que jamais nécessaire
compte tenu des prévisions
d'augmentation de la consommation
d'électricité dans les années à venir ça
pourrait augmenter de plus de 20% d'ici
2030 1 c'est ce que dit rte pour vous la
france ne pourra pas se passer d owlient
alors le débat est vraiment très très
mal posée et posé avec beaucoup
d'hypocrisie et de mauvaise foi par
barbara pompili parce que ça fait des
années qu'on sait que pour décarbonés
notre
notre économie il va falloir électrifié
nos usages on se rend pas compte mais
aujourd'hui l'électricité ça représente
que 25 % de notre consommation d'énergie
elle est encore à 75% fossile donc pour
baisser nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre n'ya qu'une seule solution c'est
d'électrifier les transports les usines
les bâtiments faire de l'électricité
alors évidemment notre consommation
électrique elle va exploser les
prévisions de tous les spécialistes des
scientifiques disent elles devraient
augmenter de 60 80 % d'ici 2050 mais le
gouvernement n'a jamais dit ça le
gouvernement ait dit non non ça va être
30% pas plus parce qu'on va faire
beaucoup d'économies et pourquoi il dit
ça parce que il veut en parallèle
réduire la part du nucléaire dans notre
mix électrique pour le passer à 50% mais
on fait quand on regarde les vrais
prévisions on voit bien ça colle pas on
peut pas avoir fermé 14 réacteurs
nucléaires ce qui est prévu et
quasiment doubler la consommation
d'électricité ça ne colle pas
aujourd'hui la barbara pompili nous dit
avait finalement ça va aller beaucoup
plus vite que prévu ll lui elle fait
mine de le découvrir de découvrir ce
qu'on savait pour dire il faut faire de
l'éolien en masse alors évidemment que
en compte tenu de ces prévisions
d'augmentation de consommation
électrique il va toutes les sources
d'électricité décarbonée devons être
mobilisés il va falloir faire du
nucléaire beaucoup plus fin en tout cas
au minimum renouveler notre parc il va
falloir faire de l'éolien il va falloir
faire du solaire mais la question qu'on
doit poser pour un débat démocratique
sain c'est à quel coût et à quel endroit
les investissements qu'on va se
consentir seront les plus et plus
efficace et c'est là que la question des
eaux liens se pose quand même parce que
on a déjà aujourd'hui dépensées 121
milliards pour développer l'éolien en
france et selon les chiffres de la cour
des comptes pour produire 6 % de notre
électricité est ce que ces 121 milliards
n'aurait pas été plus utile mis dans les
bâtiments par exemple dans la rénovation
des bâtiments dont dans
l'électrification des du parc automobile
la question doit se poser cette question
n'est jamais posé et moi je comprends
bien monsieur le maire vous parlez de
transition énergétique je ne sais pas
quel est le contexte de votre région ça
a remplacé quoi les éoliennes chez vous
qu'est l'électricité parce que si c'est
pour remplacer du décarbonés part du
décarbonés je vois pas trop l'intérêt
non mais je vous avez vous avez dit
beaucoup de choses madame ça
nécessiterait quand même des
vérifications et ou parce qu'elles
annonceraient si on n'en est pas là je
suis d'accord mais on a des informations
aussi excusez moi quand même bien qu on
n'a jamais dit madame que les énergies
renouvelables remplacerait le nucléaire
ce n'est pas vrai même y compris la
direction de la ratp d'edf dit qu'on a
besoin de la mixité énergétique y
compris le nucléaire c'est 1 2 oui ils
le disent ça il est indispensable donc
ça n'a pas remplacé si vous voulez de
l'énergie on a contribué au développer
les énergies renouvelables par contre
niveau effectif mais 14 éoliennes madame
on avec on économise à 78 1500 tonnes de
co2 non non ça c'est ça votre chine dont
il faut être précis mais celle ci
cherche entre les haines et centrales à
charbon le chiffre de juillet mais
cherche à ce combat je connais ces
chiffres par les soirs en place des
centrales à charbon des 340 question est
ce que les éoliennes participe à la
réduction de gaz à effet de serre je
vous réponds oui vous pouvez pas me
contester c'est edf c'est le rapport
qu'on a eue quand il a fallu que l'on
voit et on économise 217 kg de déchets
radio nucléides il faut donc bien de le
dire et après effectivement ça fait des
ressources pour la commune c'est je
comprends que l'on prendrait de matadi
locale samantha vous reçoit j'essaye de
répondre si vous permet un entendons
nous bien le les énergies renouvelables
n'ont jamais dit qu'on remplacerait les
sources actuelles a fait un tout cas
mieux il faut absolument diminuer le
fonctionnaire notre électricité
aujourd'hui en france est décarbonée à
88 ans ne serait pas
93% on ne conteste pas
qu'il faut rester on va manquer de tout
à l'heure si oui l'électricité est
passionnée entre vous deux mais oui je
me lasse matin smic aussi participé pas
plus mal vous avez évoqué le coup
ce matin moi je suis venu pour évoquer
le parc offshore dont on parlait tout à
l'heure c'est un exemple frappant
puisque le mégawatt produit qui serait
produit par le parc éolien de la baie de
saint brieuc sortirait à 150 euros le
mégawatt là où le mégawatt n'est que le
nucléaire est à 50 euros les 100 euros
de différence c'est les français qui
vont payer c'est à dire c'est même pas
les abonnés c'est les citoyens qui vont
le payer donc c'est un coût considérable
et on se voit
vous avez
là dessus mais juste avant de parler de
saint brieuc on voit le débat
dépassionné sur ce sujet et pourtant t
il est passionnant c'est passionnant
mais pourtant peut-être calmer la
contestation barbara pompiers a fait des
annonces cette semaine on va voir
lesquels avec son brassard car il fait
souvent des données
l'objectif du gouvernement est de rendre
l'éolien acceptable d'aider à son
développement en évitant les nombreux
recours et opposition parmi les mesures
annoncées on trouve l'obligation de
recycler plus de 90% de la structure
d'une éolienne pour lutter contre les
nuisances sonores des contrôles de bruit
seront effectuées dès 2022 surtout les
nouveaux parcs avant même leur mise en
service il est aussi prévu de réduire
l'impact lumineux des éoliennes les
signaux émis par les machines seront
strictement orienté vers le ciel une
autre partie des mesures visent une
meilleure instruction des projets en
amont avec l'obligation de consulter le
maire de la commune concernée par le
projet avant même le dépôt du dossier et
la mise en place de comités régionaux de
l'énergie chargée de définir des
objectifs de développement des énergies
renouvelables
les préfets devront s'assurer de la
compatibilité des projets avec les
enjeux environnementaux locaux et
cartographier les zones propices au
développement de l'éolien le tout avec
l'appui d'une équipe de médiateurs
relevant du ministère qui pourront être
saisis par les préfets enfin la filière
financera sur ses ventes d'électricité
un fonds de sauvegarde du patrimoine
naturel et culturel des territoires
dotés de 30 à 40 millions d'euros par an
alain cadec ces mesures elles sont les
bonnes elles sont naturelles
convaincront pas ces mesures
correspondent à 1 10 pour conques on
connaît déjà depuis longtemps
évidemment c'est des annonces 40
millions ici 50 millions là ça
correspond à peu près à la politique
gouvernementale actuellement on est à
dire qu'on distribue ici et là on parle
de on commence à s'inquiéter on voit
bien que madame pompili commencent à
s'inquiéter du rejet dans certaines dans
certains secteurs de de cette production
d'énergie notamment elle évoque le
recyclage aujourd'hui on sait pas russie
clé on sait pas recycler les pales on
sait pas recycler une durée de vie d'une
éolienne ses 20 ans bout de vingt ans il
faut l'enlever faut la détruire
aujourd'hui ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
les enfouit on est quand on enfouit
l'ailé les déchets en quelque sorte des
éoliennes donc non ces annonces ça
n'apporte strictement rien
malheureusement comme d'habitude
excusez moi monsieur le sénateur c'est
un tout petit peu pénible écoutez les
propos que vous tenez ça fait 15 ans que
je les entends vous n'allez pas me dire
qu'en 15 ans on n'a pas évolué leur
recyclage excusez moi une éolienne à
ckoi c'est de l'acier de l'aluminium et
du cuivre on sait pas recyclées non
écoutez moi comment ces notes avaient
lieu aujourd'hui on nous dit wilson en
fusion ma commère excusez moi on a
commencé à bâtir d'éolien donc en
octobre 2009 on parle de re de
repowering d'écouté des sociétés que
nous avons reçues elles vont aussi clean
éoliennes elles vont casser le béton et
traitera tout est prévu je ne comprends
pas tout est vraiment eu de la chance
oui mais écoutez je sens
venir
j'ai la prétention je voulais dire
quelque chose pardon est vite fait bien
fait saigner mais moi oui venez je vous
invite je vous invite à mon département
mais moi je vous invite dans le mille
non mais d'abord le mien parce que moi
il y en a des rôles de cheyrou y en a
pas moyen à
madame bombe d'accord avec ce qu'elle
dit si ça doit effectivement discuter
débattre et rassurer mais regardez on
fait par n'importe quoi quand même les
élus main fait écouter quand on parle de
consulter parce que vous
je vous montre
comment ça existait déjà et après le
conseil municipal il prend une
délibération pour accepter par le projet
ian kelly il ya tout un tas de jeux
d'hier de pratiques démocratiques qui
sont exercice qui font que construire ou
pas et tous les projets ne sont pas
acceptés je veux dire on a des idées
mais moi je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord je trouve qu'elle a dit quand
même elle a fait quelques annonces
intéressantes pas du tout sur
l'acceptation locale parce que moi
j'entends le débat sur les paysages et
sur ceux qui veulent pas mais ça me
semble pas le plus fondamental quand on
parle de collectivités de bien commun et
de l'été lui demande c'est un élément
bien sûr donc c'est important de cette
consultation et l'acceptabilité est
importante mais ce qui est plus
important c'est qu'elles annoncent la
création de comités régionaux de
l'énergie ça ça me semble fondamental
parce que dans énormément d'endroits il
n'y a pas de nécessité de construire
d'éoliennes simplement parce que même si
les maires level parce qu'ils y voient
effectivement le
gain politique aussi qu'on a à
s'afficher comme mr écolo à les recettes
fiscales con qu'on peut en tirer c'est
un coût pour la collectivité nationale
et est ce que ce coût doit être
supportée et on parlait du parc éolien
de la baie saint brieuc ça me semble
assez représentatif c'est un parc de 62
et éolienne qui va coûter près de 5
milliards d'euros d'argent public sur 20
ans sans conduire sans compter le
raccordement que va assumer et retire
parce qu'il faut tirer des câbles sous
marins pour raccorder tout ça au réseau
il va sans doute falloir adapter le
réseau parce que les câbles nos câbles
quelque 410 vols sont pas forcément
adaptées c'est un coût colossal et la
question se pose est-ce qu'on en a
besoin est ce que cet argent au bon
endroit moi je pense que effectivement
l'éolien offshore est important va être
un vrai atout pour décarbonés
l'électricité européenne surtout compte
tenu son facteur de charge et de plus
deux fois plus important que l'éolien
terrestre mais pas partout pas à
n'importe quel prix et là il me semble
qu'on
est parti depuis 2005 en gros depuis
2005 dans une espèce de discours
anarchique on est en retard par rapport
aux autres mais les autres ils sont
encore au gaz ou au charbon pas nous et
vous allez retard vous parliez de saint
brieuc géraldine woessner on va y aller
justement saint brieuc
d'éoliennes de plus de 200 mètres de
haut à une quinzaine de 107 m
précisément à une quinzaine de
kilomètres des côtes bretonnes dans la
baie de saint brieuc un projet ce projet
offshore suscite la colère des pêcheurs
et d'associations de défense de
l'environnement dans un contexte vous
allez le voir de plus en plus tendue
sagna de cherré jonathan du prix elles
se sont rendues sur place à la rencontre
des opposants et des défenseurs de ce
futur parc éolien en mer
par beau temps on peut apercevoir
l'aeolus ce navire perso les fonds
marins pour planter soixante deux
éoliennes de mer dont la baie de saint
brieuc d'ici 2023 un projet qui fait
l'unanimité contre lui chez les pêcheurs
ce matin grégory métayère hamas et 750
kg de saint jacques
une bonne pêche n'est pas de quoi
rattraper une saison compliquée depuis
le début des travaux de forage il assure
que le poisson se fait plus rare
depuis le début de l'été c'est nous
c'est nul
il craint que la saint-jacques soit
impactée à son tour la coquille c'est la
moitié de ses revenus si elle disparaît
grégory métayer a peur de devoir tout
arrêter après 24 ans passés en mer dans
deux ans si c'est ça on sera bien de
changer de métier
profitant
de son côté la société elle marine qui
est derrière ce projet assure que ces
futures éoliennes de mer ne présente
aucun danger pour la ressource on a pu
joindre son dirigeant par skype voici
ses arguments des études ont été menées
en particulier par des chercheurs du
cnrs sur l'impact du bruit sur les
coquilles saint jacques sur la seiche et
sur d'autres espèces emblématiques de la
baie et les conclusions montrent qu'il
n'y a pas d'impact avec des sons
beaucoup plus fort que ce nous émettons
en finalement sur au cours des travaux
des études qui n'ont convaincu ni les
pêcheurs ni l'association écologiste
garder les caps sa présidente est formel
pour elle ces futures éoliennes sont bel
et bien une menace pour la faune marine
elles vont créer un bruit chronique dans
l'eau
pendant toute la durée de l'exploitation
donc le bruit bas quel est l'effet sur
les espèces marines c'est très simple un
ça les stresse
les espèces sont stressés donc elles se
déplacent moins elles mangent moins
elles se reproduisent donc d'abord -
moins bien et puis elles finissent par
disparaître
catherine poujol ne comprend pas le
choix d'implanter des éoliennes de mer
dans la baie de saint brieuc la plus
grande réserve naturelle de bretagne il
ya 300 espèces d'oiseaux différentes en
baie de saint brieuc la plupart des
espèces protégées et des espèces en
danger critique d'extinction comme le
puffin des baléares c'est c'est
complètement c'est invraisemblable les
défenseurs de l'environnement sont en
réalité divisés sur le sujet les élus
écologistes de la région bretagne eux
estiment que le parc éolien est
nécessaire car il doit permettre de
produire l'équivalent de la consommation
annuelle de 8 135 mille personnes en
énergie soit près d'un tiers des
habitants de la région on ne néglige pas
le fait évidemment qu'il ya un impact
lors des travaux sur la biodiversité
mais c'est ça dans toute activité
humaine la question de fond c'est le
sujet de l'autonomie la transition
énergétique de la bretagne aujourd'hui
la bretagne produit très peu en termes
d'énergie il est très dépendante à la
fois de l'extérieur de la région en
termes de production est dépendante des
énergies fossiles et dépendante du
nucléaire donc à un moment donné la
vraie question c'est de savoir ce que
l'on veut et pour nous les écologistes
c'est construire cette autonomie et
cette transition énergétique les
opposants multiplient les recours en
espérant que ces éoliennes de mer ne
voit jamais le jour dans la baie de
saint brieuc et ils viennent peut-être
de gagner du temps puisque une plante
des pêcheurs a conduit le parquet
national financier à ouvrir il y a
quelques jours une enquête sur les
conditions d'attribution du marché la
société elle marine avec des soupçons
d'irrégularités
alain cadec c'est évidemment ce dossier
par coeur vous les défenseurs du projet
dire que c'est nécessaire pour
l'indépendance énergétique de la
bretagne exactement ce que vous a
répondu le gouvernement mais c'est vrai
qu'on ne produit pas d'énergie en
bretagne ne produit pas d'énergie ont
produit 15 % de ce qu'on consomme en
bretagne évidemment on est une région
excentrée périphériques il n'y a pas que
l'autre mais en l'occurrence c'est vrai
c'est pas une raison pour faire ce parc
éolien qui est un parc éolien c'est un
c'est un fiasco environnemental c'est un
fiasco économique est un fiasco
financier c'est un drame absolu ce parc
éolien je voulais 10,62 éoliennes de 2
107 mètres de haut à 15 kilomètres du
cap fréhel qui est un site classé je
veux dire c'est aberrant et le dirigeant
de dell marine a été essayé d'expliquer
qu'il avait pas de dommage sur la
biodiversité dans la construction dans
l'installation des pieux pour installer
les éoliennes c'est archi faux il n'y a
pas eu vraiment d'étude d'impact la
concertation avec les pêcheurs qui sont
les principaux utilisateurs de l'espace
maritime n'a pas eu lieu ou alors de
façon vraiment à la marge donc c'est
intolérable on peut pas laisser des
choses comme ça ce faire et encore une
fois je pense que nous devons davantage
développer notre énergie nucléaire
éventuellement avec des mini et micro
central puisqu'on en parle pas seulement
des repères mais on peut essayer de
développer ça pour justement compenser
cette ce retard que nous avons en
matière d'énergie en bretagne mais c'est
vrai ailleurs aussi plutôt que de faire
des centrales à charbon ou au gaz comme
ça se fait en allemagne et ailleurs on
est le pays d'europe le moins carbonée
ou le moins carboné sais pas comment on
peut dire est en tous les cas il faut
quand il faut qu'on le reste et c'est
pas en faisant uniquement de l'éolien du
photovoltaïque c'est important de faire
du mix suis d'accord bien sûr que c'est
important d'en faire mais c'est pas la
solution miracle non mais
je ne crois en fait c'est la question de
la vision où on veut aller et
si fait on fait de l'éolien pour
atteindre l'objectif de 50% nucléaire
dans notre mix électrique c'est
grotesque à feu il n'y a pas de raison
de faire ça l'objectif c'est émettre
moins de gaz à effet de serre ces
émetteurs en co2 donc il faut aussi
avoir conscience que l'éolien doit être
assise sur des ressources pilotable
d'énergie l'éolien est intermittent
il faut qu'on puisse pour passer les
moins d'avoir des ressources qu'ils
allaient 30 % quand il fait beau temps
sinon
on fait des eaux lien enfin l'éolien est
parfait s'il est à 6 ans pilotable sur
du nucléaire mais si on met des
centrales à gaz c'est ce que fait
l'allemagne la belgique aujourd'hui on
ferme le nucléaire et ont fait pousser
des centrales au gaz et on assume donc
le stress souvent quand vous parlez des
élus écologistes qui sont pour ses parcs
ben oui ils sont ils sont pour la sortie
du nucléaire donc c'est il ya de la
cohérence maintenant il faut aussi je
voudrais simplement redire quelques
chiffres pour que les électeurs et des
ordres de grandeur en tête qui font
partie du débat public des citoyens les
électeurs qui n'ont pas un réacteurs
nucléaires de 900 mégawatts aujourd'hui
les classiques un réacteur pour le
remplacer il faut 2000 et éolienne
terrestre et 3 140 éoliennes offshore de
8 mégawatts telle celle qu'on va art
dans la baie de saint brieuc voilà un
réacteur 3 140 éoliennes offshore on
peut le faire mais il faut encore une
fois je le répète le faire à bon escient
et bien être conscient de ce qu'on
remplace avec pas n'importe où n'importe
comment et à n'importe quel prix c'est
vrai vous avez raison plutôt oui non
mais très très simplement moi j'insiste
on n'a jamais dit que les énergies
renouvelables remplacerait les énergies
actuelle d'abord on parle que de
l'électricité il ya tout le reste est
bien d'accord après on est bien d'accord
que les ressources elles vont elles vont
diminuer voire elles vont disparaître au
cours de ce 21e siècle si un fonçage dit
il faudrait remplacer vous oubliez à mon
avis dans votre appréciation c'est les
économies d'énergie c'est un passage
obligé année deux deuxièmes des choses
je vous le dis encore là tu veux vous
parler du coût des énergies
renouvelables écoutez moi j'attends
madame j'attends je lirai vos articles
le coot réel du nucléaire parce qu'ils
coûtent aujourd'hui dans les oubliées
joli match année sans oublier le
recyclage le démantèlement selon m
mais par exemple éolien canton il faut
le dire aujourd'hui l'éolien c'est 40
euros le mégawatt il faut le dire non il
faut
vous rendez sur
le moment ça que je dis que débat public
est biaisé mais
le coup qu'on nous donne c'est le cou à
la sortie de taling qu'à la sortie de
l'éolienne leur déclin pas c'est le coup
chez moi quand j'allume l'interrupteur
et votre bonne inclut pas les caves
n'inclut pas le back up de l'ouverture
comme à saint brieuc puisque la justice
est saisie ont la vue l'ouïe c'est à
dire que le conseil d'état a rejeté de
marché alors le conseil d'état a rejeté
le marché et le pnf s'est saisi du
dossier parce que le marché est
irrégulier
moi je rentre pas dans ce dans ce dans
ce domaine à dans le domaine du bnf dans
le domaine juridique judiciaire c'est
pas mon problème mais oui j'espère
l'arrêt mais sur le fond c'est à dire
l'arrêt de l'arrêt du chantier et
éventuellement passer à 1 de l'éolien
flottant c'est une solution tout à fait
envisageable mais par contre on peut
qu'on pourrait le mettre beaucoup plus
loin des côtes avec des éoliennes -
haute et qui produisent autant
d'électricité dont je suis pas opposés à
l'éolien totalement c'est pas ça le
problème j'ai complètement d'accord avec
avec madame ça doit être un complément
mais il faut qu'on reste avec notre
production nucléaire c'est important
parce qu'on a on a une électrice
résister décarbonés en france ce serait
quand même malheureux de 2,2 d'être
obligé à un moment ou un autre de
construire des centrales à charbon des
centrales à gaz j'en passe et des
meilleurs donc bas et d'autres pays
ici les affirmations de madame pompidou
sur les affirmations purement dans l'air
comme ça
dans la campagne présidentielle mario
wii est en fait les audiences et déjà
invité dans la campagne des régionales
c'était en juin dernier en particulier
en région au de france il faut savoir
que le territoire est celui qui compte
le plus d'éoliennes en france 2500
devant la région grand est et je vous
propose d'écouter lors du débat du
premier tour la position de xavier
bertrand on va être clair
l'éolien basta terminé terminer le
développement le nucléaire encore le
nucléaire encore parce que on veut une
énergie décarbonée alors chez le
nucléaire et pour moi c'est une énergie
d'avenir et puis encore une fois j'en
reviens à cela l'emploi cette position
défendue au mois de juin elle reste la
même aujourd'hui valérie pécresse et
michel barnier plaident eux aussi pour
une relance de la politique nucléaire ce
refus de l'éolien il est aussi portée
par le rassemblement national c'est
d'ailleurs l'un des thèmes sur lequel
marine le pen n'a pas varié ces
dernières années comme elle le défend
des déjà lors de la campagne
présidentielle de 2010 17 les éoliennes
sont à ses yeux inefficace voire
contre-productive et trop cher et
écouter cet échange qui date justement
de 2007 je ne veux pas d eau lien ne
m'en marc nulle part nulle part voilà
c'est c'est épouvantable c'est cher
sûrement certaines entreprises
ont été très heureuse de nous les vendre
mais la réalité c'est que c'est une
vraie pollution non seulement visuel
mais je crois que nous découvrirons dans
le futur probablement les conséquences
que ça sur la santé des habitants qui
vivent autour de ces éoliennes gauche eh
bien on est très partagé je ne vous
apprends pas organe que les verts les
écologistes sont favorables aux
éoliennes et à leur développement le
candidat yannick jadot expliquait
d'ailleurs à nos confrères du télégramme
en septembre dernier je cite il faut
aller vers l'éolien et aussi vers
l'éolien offshore quelle que soit
l'énergie il ya pollution il faut
développer l'éolien offshore créer des
milliers d'emplois et permettre à une
indépendance énergétique jean luc
mélenchon lui plaide pour 100%
d'énergies renouvelables d'ici à 2030
afin de sortir du nucléaire quand le
communiste fabien roussel défend le
nucléaire lui qui voit dans les
éoliennes du brassage de vent qui ne
produit pas grand chose enfin anne
hidalgo soutient la filière mais hier
dans un entretien au journal libération
elle temporise également voici ce
qu'elle dit même si on fait de la
sobriété énergétique on a des besoins il
faut organiser en urgence en débat
public sur les éoliennes y sur les
énergies renouvelables
il faut discuter et non imposer ce sera
un thème merci marion ce sera un thème
de la campagne présidentielle bien sûr
là je constate que majoritairement à
droite comme à gauche une opposition et
une opposition à l'éolien mais pas une
opposition frontale c'est à dire une
opposition à l'éolien n'importe où
n'importe comment comme vous le disiez
et à n'importe quel prix et c'est la
position de xavier bertrand d'ailleurs
c'est pas contre l'éolien c'est contre
les rien n'importe où n'importe comment
à n'importe quel prix donc je pense
qu'il va falloir qu'on arrête c'est
peut-être juste de faire réagir à ce
sondage doxa pour le figaro il ya
quelques jours qui résume peut-être le
débat est ce que vous nous avez dit il
ya 63 % des français qui voient dans
bones l'éolien mais en a 53 % qui ne
veulent pas d'une éolienne à côté de
chez eux mais parce qu'en fait ça ce nom
alors déjà c'est une partie du problème
oui à une question ce que je déplore
dans ce débat et j'espère que cette
campagne va être l'occasion de remettre
un peu de rationalité dans ces échanges
on a eu et on n'a rien eu de rationnel
depuis quinze ans que le que l'éolien se
développe on a eu des mythes on a eu des
mensonges on a eu des lobbys qui ont
appuyé dévoile à des modèles économiques
moi ce que je voudrais c'est composent
les faits sur la table de quoi on aura
besoin demain on parle de
réindustrialiser le pays comment on fait
on parle d'indépendance
est-ce qu'on est indépendant quand on
dépend des terres rares qui sont
exclusivement produites en chine pour
fabriquer six éoliennes colmant contient
l'uranium s'est diversifiée on apporte
d'australie du canada à cléon du
kazakhstan du niger oui on sait c'est
moins dangereux
dépendance énergétique de la
mettre sur la table je vous réponds vous
avez raison de mettre sur la table le
métier il ya une réponse donc oui et
c'est ça qu'on doit mais en cliquant
dans les landes et que l'éolien l'éolien
divise l'éolien 10 11 alors
va créer un débat important pour la
l'élection présidentielle c'est vrai
merci
[Musique]